Hey Youtubers it's Charlie and and since we
know that one of the first three Star Wars
spinoff movies is going to be Boba Fett I
wanted to talk about what that might look
like. It's not going to be the first spinoff
they do, so it will be a while before we see
it. But it's totally possible that the bones
of the Boba Fett movie could come from a super
cool video game that never ended up happening,
Star Wars 1313. So this video is going to
be a breakdown of that and why I think it's
a great starting point for the people working
on the movie. I'll also talk about where production
of the spinoffs compared to the main sequels.
If you're finding me for the first time I'm
going to be doing Star Wars bonus videos every
week during the summer. Be sure to subscribe
to get everything. And feel free to leave
me suggestions for bonus videos. I'm going
to try and post them on Tuesdays, but I've
been out of town so that's why you're seeing
this now.
So production update first. Garreth Edwards
who just directed Godzilla was hired to direct
the first Star Wars spinoff movie. They didn't
announce the title, but they did say it's
going to come out December 16th, 2016. Right
now the rumored sequels are Han Solo, Boba
Fett and Red Five as in an X-Wing Rebel Story.
I think the first Spinoff is going to be the
Red Five story. Mostly because the biggest
names attached to the spinoffs, Lawrence Kasdan
and Simon Kinberg are probably working on
the biggest spinoffs. Han Solo and Boba Fett.
And it seems only natural that they would
give the easier story to do to the newer director.
That's just my opinion.
We can talk more about what those other spinoffs
might look like in a future video, but now
let's talk about Boba Fett. For a long time
he was the coolest Star Wars character. Darth
Vader was always the face of the franchise,
but in the 90s before all the big Prequel
and Disney stuff started. It always seemed
like hardcore Star Wars fans were always more
interested in talking about Boba Fett. He
was just way more mysterious.
Because everything we know about him right
now comes from the Expanded Universe literature
and the prequels, Disney is probably going
to change a lot of things. We'll talk about
that in a sec. I think there's a really good
chance they could use the Star Wars 1313 game
that died as inspiration for the look and
tone of the movie. It's like a Dark Noir crime
drama.
In case you never heard about the game, Lucasarts
showed off footage at E3 in 2012. It featured
an 'unnamed' bounty hunter deep in the Underworld
Coruscant, Level 1313 as the title implies.
What made the game different was that it didn't
feature Jedi Powers. It was more like Battlefront
and you had to use technology and hand to
hand combat skills.
Later it was revealed that the narrative of
the game was going to tell the story of Boba
Fett's early years as a bounty hunter. Cut
from thunderous applause to dead silence.
Lucasarts was later shut down and the game
was scrapped. Disney has announced no plans
to ressurect the game itself, but from a visual
standpoint it's perfect for the Boba Fett
spinoff movie.
It addresses a lot of the issues fans had
with the prequels looking so bright and shiny.
Everything just seemed way too clean to be
threatening. I always loved the steam punky
look of the original trilogy, and this game
took most of it's inspiration
from that.
If you saw that video JJ Abrams posted about
winning a chance to cameo in Star Wars 7,
you could see a real life puppet creature
next to him. That film is shooting on film
stock. Not Digital like the prequels. So it
seems like these new Star Wars films are going
to look a lot more like the Original Trilogy.
So the 1313 Boba Fett Game totally fits with
that ideology.
Looking at the Concept Art for the game I
see a couple of potential issues. First, these
are going to be Disney movies. And even their
darker stories have a certain Disney-fied
look to them. Tangible and Real but very polished.
The Boba Fett concept art is way darker and
dirtier. So I don't think they'd do exactly
what you're seeing here.
And second, Disney made it a point to say
the writers were starting fresh when it came
to story. So if they do use this Boba Fett
Game as inspiration. A lot of the story would
be changed. I don't think that's a bad thing.
Concept Art is exactly that, just a concept.
One really cool thing was that in that game,
Boba Fett had a droid companion. The droid
was eventually supposed to double cross him,
which seems only natural for a Boba Fett story.
It reminds me of HK-47 from Knights of the
Old Republic. In KOTOR, HK was actually built
by Revan to hunt down Jedi.
The Rebels Cartoon that's premiering in the
fall is going to tell that story, the Empire's
process of hunting down the last of the Jedi
after the events of Return of The Jedi. I
know a lot of you have been asking me about
that show and yes I will be doing weekly videos
for it when it premieres. They've only said
fall, but I'm expecting it to drop in October.
There's going to be 16 episodes total.
As for the timing of the Star Wars movies,
they've only announced official released dates
for Episode 7 and that first Spinoff. But
Hasbro leaked some information based on star
wars toy release dates. Here's the breakdown
of everything.
First there's the Rebels Cartoon this fall
in 2014, that's confirmed. Then there's Episode
7 December 18th 2015 that's confirmed. Then
the first Star Wars Spinoff on December 16,
2016. Also confirmed. Unofficially that's
probably going to be the Red Five movie.
Then there's Episode 8 in 2017 probably a
December release in keeping with their theme.
Next is the second Spinoff movie in December
2018, which could either be Han Solo or Boba
Fett. Then Episode 9 in 2019 and the third
spinoff movie in 2020.
Take all of that with a grain of salt. Movies
get delayed and moved around all the time.
Generally though Disney is going to release
a Star Wars movie every year. That's their
goal. But somewhere along the way one of the
core sequels like Episode 9, could always
be delayed.
They make so much money on them though. If
they ever did run into schedule problems they
probably wouldn't hesitate to throw money
at the problem to get them out faster.
So I hope that you guys agree that they should
totally use that 1313 Game as inspiration
for the Boba Fett movie. Production hasn't
started yet and it's still in the script phase
so I don't think they'll be releasing official
information about it for a long time.
Now it's your turn though. Let me know what
you think a Boba Fett movie should look like
and do you think they should just erase all
the prequel backstory?
My next Star Wars video will probably be my
top 10 picks for characters I'd like to see
in Episode 7. Be sure to subscribe to get
it. Now that my schedule is almost back to
normal I should be able to post it next Tuesday.
There's also a lot of cool stuff happening
this weekend. Be sure to go see Maleficent.
Right now click here for my Maleficent Review,
I'll be posting it Friday Morning. Don't worry
there will be spoiler warnings. And click
here for my Breakdown of the Episode 7 cast.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!